- So nice.
- [Kelly] I'm very
excited actually having...
You are such a great actor,
and you are so funny--
- Oh, thanks.
- [Kelly] And I love you,
and everything you do.
- Well, thank you, likewise.
- [Kelly] I'm starting with that.
- I'm a huge, huge fan of yours.
- Oh, well, you don't have
to say that, but thank you.
- [Adam] I don't.
- You didn't!
So, you have kids,
so are they obsessed with "Encanto"?
Have you seen it a ton?
- I haven't.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I don't know if they've seen it.
- [Kelly] What?
- I don't know my kids very well.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- Oh, are they older or--
- They're teenagers.
They're 13 and 15.
- Okay, okay.
- So, whatever they see and do,
I have to pry it out of them.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But, we still watch everything together
and this is right up their alley.
So, I'm assuming they have seen it.
- [Kelly] Okay, it's so good.
- I know, I've heard it's incredible,
so I do, I have to watch it.
- Yeah.
Yeah, Lin, it's rude how talented he is.
- Yes, I know.
- Yeah.
- [Adam] And she does
look like the character.
- She does, it was crazy.
- [Adam] I know enough to know
that that's a good match.
- Yes.
Your daughter seems very organized though,
because you posted this
to-do list that she made,
which I love.
- [Adam] Yeah,
that's it.
- First of all,
my daughter does this.
- [Adam] She does?
- [Kelly] She makes lists,
and if we don't cross them off,
she's like "We haven't done this yet",
which is a stall tactic for bedtime.
- Did she get that from you?
- Yes, I am annoyingly organized.
- Okay, good, good.
- Yeah.
- That's good.
- Are you like that?
- [Adam] No.
- No?
- No.
- [Kelly] Where did this come from?
- Her mother.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, no.
But I admire it,
and I wish that I had
half of the brain that she has.
- Is she still this organized?
- [Adam] Absolutely.
- Wow.
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- She's a very organized 13-year-old.
- [Kelly] I love efficiency.
- Me too.
- So, wait, that was your
daughter being organized.
- Yes.
- So, I did find this
from your son.
So, this is your son.
- [Adam Scott] Oh yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] So, I'm just
gonna go ahead and say it,
that's scary as hell, man.
- [Adam] It is scary.
- If I came around a corner
at this store, I would...
It's awesome.
- That was at Michaels, I believe, and--
- Sure, as you do.
- That's right.
(Kelly laughs)
I saw this happening, and
it just warmed my heart.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
Because that...
- That's your son.
- If I could pull it off, I would do it.
But he did it, and it freaked
people in the store out.
And I just couldn't get enough.
It was a proud moment.
- What I relate to though
is my son dresses up.
Like even we go out.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Like he was Kroopa,
like in Mario Brothers.
- Oh, really?
- So, he'll wear characters
to the store.
- [Adam] Sure.
- Yeah.
He just thinks it's hilarious.
Normal clothes is beneath him.
- Yeah, it's not fun
to wear normal clothes.
- He doesn't go scary though,
but that was awesome.
- That's frightening.
- If I turned the corner--
- Yes.
I would definitely be like...
- And I would be like "I'm sorry".
- "Who are your parents?"
- "But I love this."
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- So, tell everybody what
the new show is about.
- The new show is about a company
that has a procedure where you can get
a little thing inserted into your brain,
not a big deal.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
Where it splits your
life into two sections.
When you go to work,
you cross the threshold of your job
and you have no idea who you
are in the outside world.
Your whole life is there at work.
And then, when you leave work and go home,
you have no clue what your job is.
You don't know what you do.
- That's a crazy cool concept.
- Yeah, it just separates the two.
So, you can just enjoy
your life out in the world
and not worry about work.
And you can just focus on your work
and not worry about the outside world
- Are you good at
compartmentalization in life?
Can you separate when you get home?
Do you shut off?
- I think my job is hard.
It just blurs the boundaries
all over the place.
And also, for everyone now I kinda feel,
like with devices and stuff,
you're always kind of working, right?
There's no really putting it down,
unless you lock it away.
- I try not to.
I do put it down.
- [Adam] You do, that's good.
- Yeah, she'll tell you,
my assistant will literally be like,
"So, have you seen the emails?"
- [Adam] Yeah.
- And I'm like, "Yes, but I
livin' my life right now."
- Yeah.
Sometimes, I don't even open--
- It's hard to do it.
- The emails 'cause I don't wanna know.
- I have so many blue dots.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- Seriously, how many
unopened emails do you have?
- I feel ashamed, but
around 26,000, I think.
(audience murmurs)
Look, and a lot of those are liars.
They're companies that tell
you you can unsubscribe,
you press unsubscribe--
- 100 percent.
- You're never unsubscribed.
They just send you (beep) for days.
(audience applauds)
- How many times have you
unsubscribed from things
and you keep getting them?
- Why lead me on?
Exactly, they're liars.
- Total (beep).
- Yeah.
I've got about 26 grand emails,
like 26,000.
- No joke.
- Grand?
- I think it's right here,
but I think I'm right there with you.
- It's bad.
- About 26,000.
- But I do think it's important
that we do learn how to shut off,
but I also think it's
a really cool concept,
because it's like,
being able to actually
live those two lives.
- [Adam] That's it.
- Without one impacting
the other is nice.
- That's right.
Unless the company that's doing it--
- Is like evil?
- Has some nefarious,
which, in the show, they may or may not.
You have to watch to find out.
But there might be
something sinister going on,
we don't know.
- Very exciting, great cast.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- John Turturro and Patricia Arquette
and Christopher Walken.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, great people.
- [Kelly] Incredible cast.
- [Adam] Ben Stiller directed it, so.
- [Kelly] Oh wow, I didn't know that!
- Yep.
- Oh, that's incredible.
It's a really cool concept.
I love the fresh ideas.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That have never been done.
That's rare.
- It's like a whole new world
that they built, it's cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah, very Aladdin.
Okay, I like it, another Disney reference.
- That's right.
- You got it in there.
Earlier, we saw a picture of your son,
so here you are as a kid,
which is adorable.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And now, you remind me of my son.
- [Adam] Uh-huh.
- Is it a boy thing?
Because here's the thing,
my son will full on look
you right in the face
while talkin' and gettin' somethin'.
- Oh, yeah.
- I'm like,
"You know, I'm sitting here
and I can see you picking your booger?"
- [Adam] Yeah.
- It's awesome.
- Yeah.
- It's a boy thing, I think.
- I think you're right.
- Okay.
- I mean, I think that--
- I think girls, we're shady
but we'll hide about it,
we're hiding, yeah.
- Yeah, you still do it.
- Yeah, little girls
are hidden.
- But you just have--
- But they're hidden.
My daughter, I'll catch.
- You have the decency not to do that
when the camera comes, right?
(audience and Kelly laughs)
- This is awesome though.
- Yeah.
I think I thought I was being hilarious
and not knowing that one day,
it would be broadcast on
the "Kelly Clarkson Show".
- You're welcome.
You're welcome.
That's what we're here for.
- Thank you very much.
- Just to make you
just bring it down.
- Appreciate it.
- So wait, what's something
that your parents let you do
that you'd never let your kids do?
- Oh, they used to...
I got really into the
Grateful Dead for a while.
I don't know if you ever
got into the Grateful Dead.
- Wow.
When I was a teenager, it was--
- I know the type of people
that were into Grateful Dead.
- Sure, and that was me,
for two years.
- Yes.
- And I don't think
they were aware exactly
what the Grateful Dead entailed,
but they would drive me
to Grateful Dead concerts.
They let me take a bus up to
San Francisco with a friend
to go to a Grateful Dead show.
- Wow.
- And spend the night in San...
I mean this was like a while ago.
This would never happen now, right?
- I would never allow my kids.
- Never.
- Yeah, no.
- I remember my dad
drove us up to a venue,
and he's like, "Okay guys",
me and a friend of mine,
and as soon as he pulled up,
people surrounded the car
and was offering to sell him shrooms.
(audience laughs)
- And he still was like,
"Go have a good time, son."
- Was like, "Yeah, have fun,
"what is this?
(Kelly laughs and claps)
It's the Grateful Dead,
it's not a big deal.
- It is funny.
I never was home.
I was on my bike until the sun
went down, I had to be home.
- [Adam] Same.
- They never knew where I was.
- You leave in the morning.
- I would never let my kids.
- And you're gone all day.
- Yeah, but maybe the problem is us,
because I feel like they did all right.
I'm all right.
- You're fine.
- I mean I am in therapy,
but I'm all right.
- Yeah.
- But I feel like everyone
should be in therapy, by the way.
- Whether you left home all day or not.
- Whether you need it at
that specific moment or not.
But my point is,
is that maybe we should
give them more freedom.
I don't know.
'Cause I had so much
freedom just like that.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
Me too.
I mean and I think if we
did, they would be fine.
- [Kelly] I know.
- But it's still hard not--
- What's wrong with us?
Control freaks, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Apparently.
I don't know,
I think we just learned
something together, Adam.
- [Adam] I think you're right.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- Probably won't change though.
They're not going out on their own.
- No way.
No way.
- So, in "Parks and Rec", you
got to meet Joe Biden, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I got to meet him.
He was so nice.
- He's the coolest.
- [Kelly] So, what was
your experience like?
- It was great.
He came on, he had a role on the show.
Like he was obviously playing himself,
but he was so good and such a pro,
like really good on
camera, knew his lines.
And then we did another
episode where he and Dr. Biden
were both on, or the
First Lady were both on,
and they were the best, they're so nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah, they're very sweet.
- Yeah.
- Behind the scenes, that's
what I thought was the coolest.
She was asking me about just life,
like kids, normal stuff.
- Totally.
- And I was like, oh, okay,
you're being normal, okay, cool.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- And not that you're not
normal, but you know--
- Yeah, and he's like,
"Adam, how are you?"
And will shake your hand.
And you're like, oh, okay,
there's this magic thing here
where you're making me feel like
I'm the most important
person in the world.
- I know, I know.
And then you start divulging stuff.
- Yeah.
- Actually...
- And you're like, yeah.
- Can I tell you about something
that happened to me
when I was a little kid.
- My childhood, yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he's like, "No, I'm
not actually into that."
- My Mom let me go see
the Grateful Dead and--
- [Adam] That's right.
That's right.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Kelly.
- I love you,
on screen, but I love
you even more in person.
- Likewise.